hello brother how you doing i got my son  here i do it bro i see your face take  time you post everything of course i  remember here  great to see you how you been you look  good man thank you brother  how are you  how are you  appreciate it brother happy new year i  can get it for dinner but now i got it  let's go you know  brother  don't keep the light moving  i'm going back inside i'll see you guys  soon leon what's good we'll see you soon  how are you bro over here  what up gary  good to see you  you're welcome thank you bro thank you  hi thanks for coming good brother good  to see you bro thanks for coming thank  you for coming thank you gotcha i got  you you got a nice pop you got all sorts  thanks for being here appreciate you  very much you're welcome thank you man  thanks for being here  my first nft outboard thank you bro  that's what's up happy birthday julie  hope to meet you soon  all right i gotta go  [Music]